on the fight to stop the corona virus is
going on throughout the US government
including a Pentagon agency known for
out-of-the-box innovation three years
ago the Defense Advanced Research
Projects Agency known as DARPA set the
very ambitious goal of stopping disease
outbreak in just 60 days first on CBS
this morning we have an inside look at
that project it's in the middle of its
first real test senior investigative
correspondent Catherine Herridge is at
the Pentagon it's more on the story
Catherine I have to say I like how these
people are thinking but realistically
how realistic is it and how soon could
it work oh good morning Gail DARPA has a
reputation for being ahead of the curve
and right now they're hunting for the
most potent antibodies to combat kovin
19 and while clinical trials can take
years DARPA says it can't wait people
say that's impossible you can't do it
well that's what we're here to do that's
the goal DARPA DARPA one of the
Pentagon's most mysterious agencies is
usually hidden you won't find any signs
outside its headquarters in suburban
Washington DC but pandemic prevention
platform manager Amy Jenkins told me
DARPA inventions are all around us
Internet the internet not just that
everything from Siri to stealth
technology to self-driving cars even
your phone's GPS now with hope of a
corona virus vaccines still uncertain
DARPA is zeroing in on something faster
it's like a temporary fix for kovat 19 a
temporary fix it's meant to put up
firebreak around the pandemic by sifting
through the blood of koban 19 survivors
DARPA hopes to identify and clone the
genetic blueprint of the most powerful 1
2 3 antibodies that best fight the virus
we got to find that needle in the
haystack that's a game-changer it is and
it's absolutely revolutionary DARPA
funded four teams of antibody detectives
blood from the first known koba 19
survivor in the US was flown here to rob
Carnahan's lab at Vanderbilt University
along with other samples from survivors
infected at the outbreaks epicenter in
Wuhan
China after reviewing over 3000
antibodies they're now down to just a
handful they hope will best combat the
virus the most potent antibodies will be
grown in giant steel tanks that look
like beer fermenters called bio reactors
DARPA wants to take the concept to the
next level we have said rather than
doing this and those big bio reactors
let's turn our body into the bioreactor
in upcoming clinical trials they hope to
inject people with the genetic code and
then the cells take up the blueprint
unlike a vaccine investigators say these
antibodies could provide protection
within hours not weeks with about a
million Americans infected and more than
50,000 dead DARPA hopes their project
could provide temporary protection in
time for an anticipated second wave for
high-risk groups our health care workers
are frontline first responders and then
even potentially maybe the the close
personal contacts of those who are
infected but DARPA Spri Mary mission is
safeguarding US troops who often deploy
quickly to global outbreaks so I don't
want us to use the word opportunity but
in some ways this is an opportunity for
us to make sure we learn all of the
potential lessons we can learn with this
and apply those lessons learned to be
more prepared the next time there is
gonna be a next time there is going to
be a next time
on the timeline the scientists we spoke
to said they hope to have identified the
best antibodies any day now and start
clinical trials as early as this summer
that way they hope to be prepared if
there is another wave of coronavirus
later this year Gail well Katherine
we're cheering them on a temporary fix
sounds pretty good under these
circumstances thank you very much